we're going to push this pawn onto b3
and some of you might be saying wait a
second you're making this pawn easier to
capture now he can walk his king to c3
and take it
and that's exactly what he's going to do
and that's exactly the point because by
taking it
he allows us to transition to a pawn end
game where not only we're up a pawn
but additionally his king is all the way
over there
so we can open up the center
and bring our own king into the king's
side that's a lot of moving parts
so what would be
the best move here well we can play e5
immediately
there is a bit of a complex reason guys
that e5 is not the best move
flecky from poland let's go e4
and my guess is he'll play e5 yeah let's
go d4
and will he take the pun will he be our
first danish gambit victim
oh he will not be so d6 is not a bad
move and we talked about this move
earlier where
essentially we can take on e5 and some
people might be really attracted to the
possibility of
making black loses castling rights but
remember as i've said
last time when you trade queens losing
castling rights is
less effective it's it's less meaningful
it's still meaningful but it's less
meaningful so instead of that
let's transpose them to the philidor
with knight f3 all right
philidor is still very good for white
and it preserves the queens we're trying
to play aggressively so when possible
we're avoiding end games
f6 okay so
that's again you can see how how often
people make the mistake of playing f3 or
f6 so feingold's advice exists for a
reason
and here we should immediately
understand the drawback of f6 it weakens
this diagonal that's its main problem it
also weakens this diagonal
and so we should exploit the first of
these by getting the bishop out to c4
that's it that makes it very hard for
black to castle
so already his position is very tough
and i'm assuming he's going to play
bishop g4 thank you alexander i
appreciate it
so in this position there are many ways
of developing our pieces right the
obviou sort of the
typical move i suppose would be nice e3
but after knight c3 bishop g4 this pawn
on d4
will be under quite a bit of pressure
and i'm not a big fan of that so
one very good way of playing in these
positions
well explaining the fact that we haven't
gotten our net out yet we could play h3
that's fine
h3 is a great move scan 1459 thank you
for the prime but also
how can we support this pawn in the most
direct way bishop g8 i'll explain after
the game c3 yeah
i will explain the alternatives and why
i didn't play them afterwards
including bishop g and d5 a5
all right so one of the great thing
great things about c3 it defends the
pawn but that's not the only thing it
does
it also opens up a pathway for this
queen to come to b3
but if we do that immediately if we play
queen b3 in this position attacking the
knight
what does black have and this move a5
from that perspective is actually kind
of ingenious
he can play the move a4 attacking the
queen
forcing it to move so let's actually
play a for ourselves
to prevent him from doing that because
i'm trying to pave the way for queen b3
that might end up in very quick
checkmate assuming that he plays
someone like b6 or something i don't
know what i don't know what he'll do
okay knight h6 so whoa there
he's giving us an all-you-can-eat buffet
here
is bishop takes h6 a good idea that's
the
first and most obvious question that we
have to answer
let me be very clear the reason that
it's a good idea
is not because black will have double h
bonds it's because the king on e8
is going to be a lot easier to access
because the pawn structure around the
king
is going to be ruined there's one
particular thing that's going to be the
easiest of all to access and that is the
h5 square
a potential check on h5 with the queen
will no longer
black will no longer have as a response
to move g7 to g6 and that
is crucial so we have to think about
where we put this knight to pave the way
for queen h5 and ideally we would choose
the night move
that yields the most benefit what does
that mean well you can think of we can
approach this a couple of different ways
we don't have a particularly appetizing
night move with tempo
get sacrificed on e5 but that leads to
some complications i'll talk about them
after the game
i don't find that move particularly
convincing
barring that we can put the knight on a
square where the knight itself
will later be able to come into the
attack so not knight g1 knight knight d2
but rather knight h4 and you'll see this
very often this knight can later come
into the game with a knight f5 right
i hope that logic makes sense we could
have also gone queen b3
and tried to stick a bishop on f7 but
that would have been less clinical
and now black is in massive trouble he's
actually inviting our queen at h5
king e7 will get checkmated in one movie
he's got to play king d7 here
all right king he does now here
there's two ways to go about it if
you've done your puzzles
you'll notice the relationship here
between the queen and the rook
results in the possibility of what move
yeah we can go
knight g6 and that's a sort of
materialistic approach there's nothing
wrong with that we can win the exchange
that's fine
but you know with the white pieces we're
going instead for the more direct
attacking options
queen f7 shaq is super super tempting
but he blocks the queen and by blocking
with the queen listen carefully
so these these things can be hard to
follow so you really want to be locked
in here
after queen f7 queen e7 his king
has access to this escape square nda we
don't want to
let him have that so instead if we're
patient
we can notice that this h49 now can come
into f5 and the bishop on c8 is no
longer able to take it
so let's bring the knight in with knight
f5 thank you andrew exalted for the tier
one
notice how i'm i've done this twice now
i'm patiently bringing pieces into the
attack
when i don't have an immediate path to
checkmate
and these kinds of moves are what elude
a lot a lot of beginners a lot of
players who struggle with finishing
people off
in these attacking positions um
that's what they really struggle with is
these patient moves all right so queen
eight
is a great thought because he wants to
trade queens but
we have now three pieces in the attack
and we can use one of them
to send black away then we have a
very pretty pattern boom bishop f7 get
out of there
after queen d8 my logic indicates two
things first of all
look at his king carefully when
the king doesn't have any more squares
to escape
that's the moment that you should start
explicitly and
directly looking for checkmating
patterns and checkmating tactics
the way you should do that is by
considering from what squares
checkmate could be delivered not only
squares that are currently protected
because you could set up a move right
if you look at that well what squares
could we checkmate the king from
one of them is e6 bishop e6 would be
checkmate
but that square is not currently
protected but the pawn
we can push it we attack the knight but
mainly we thread bishop e6 champion he's
probably gonna go 97
but it doesn't matter where he puts
tonight he actually can't stop it yeah
this should be six i mean that's a very
pretty mate
look at how our three pieces are
beautifully cooperating and a fourth
piece the pawn
is guarding one of the escape squares
simultaneously
acting as the anchor to the bishop that
was really nice
and we're over a thousand
yay okay so first of all
why is this so this isn't bad
this is not bad x1 please stop spamming
the same question
yes it is this is not bad
white is slightly better here but
without explaining any variations
the fact of the matter is that when you
trade queens it's just harder to attack
the king and so when black loses
castling rights it's less meaningful
because often times in the end
the king wants to enter the game through
the center anyway
and black has this way of perching the
king on c7 with c6 and king c7
that often hides it from the immediate
danger of a check on d1
hopefully that makes sense we're not
going to look at the lines here
knight f3 transposes into the philidor
and f6 is a pretty bad move
okay bishop c4 knight c6 now this move
c3
i explained a5 a4 and what i mean here
is queen b3
a4 attacks the queen we can give a check
on f7
and if he goes king d7 queen e6 is
checkmate but unfortunately he goes king
e7 and now we're in trouble
because this battery is really uh frayed
by the fact that the queen is attacked
and after queen d5
black has kind of a sexy move here uh to
attack the queen can you guys spot it
thank you aussie demand
why is c3 better than bishop e3
yeah so he justifies pushing that pawn
so there was a question about why c3
is better than bishop p3 and i always
repeat this don't be shy about asking
questions i'm
that's that's what makes this i think
even better
so bishop e3 this doesn't follow the
principle that you should do stuff with
the least valuable piece when possible
pawns are best defended by other pawns
because that builds pawn chains and
that's the most solid kind of pawn
structural construction thank you ram
dog for the gift of oca
in addition it prepares queen b3 so this
just does more
okay so a4 not h6
here we take it and here i thought
people were a little bit flustered you
know why didn't we make a more active
move of the night well
i can't answer that question r3na with a
prime
so first of all knight g5 the problem
that you're going to run into here
is that there is simply no checkmate
there is simply
no checkmate i mean this is the same
position in the game except we had a
knight on h4 so that
doesn't work and i take c5
comes closer to working remember this
pattern if he plays f takes e5 there's
something in puzzle rush
that's very similar to this there is a
puzzle that's super similar and has the
same pattern after queen h5 king d7
white has a checkmate in two moves can
you guys spot it
this can be hard to find it's a weird
there's something weird about it that
makes it hard to see
yeah it's the lateral check queen f5
and wherever the king goes you made him
on f7 so
that construction happens pretty often
the problem is black can play
um d takes e5 oh oh
why is that 94 bomb gifted damn girl and
mag on 100 bits
oh man thank you thank you i appreciate
it
i appreciate it the problem here is that
even king e7 is not that easy to put
down
because the king now has the d6 square
and king d7 is even better because
here black can block the track kind of
like he would in the game
so be very careful remember
one sec
right okay
so remember the thing about sacrificing
is that
when you watch like me play or something
you might think that sacrificing is some
sort of
obligatory component of an attack but
it's really not
some of the nicest attacks are ones that
don't feature any sacrifices but rather
feature these moves which
are crystal clear in their logic such as
getting the knight involved and
preparing queen h5
um so yeah so somebody asked yeah yeah
so so the same pattern here right black
goes queen e7
and now black has the d8 score for
risking so this just doesn't work
thank you velocimientes for the 1200
okay so knight h4h5 takes
now let's move knight f5 um
and that is the best move like according
to the engine or at least one of the
best rep it's top move right now
so the engine really likes these moves
these slow moves that bring the queen
into the game
queen e8 now bishop f7 and now the key
move of course is d5
right attacking the knight but mainly
preparing checkmate on e6 this is a very
straightforward attack one which
featured three pieces it abides by the
two piece rule
most attacks i think you know you
basically need a minimum of two pieces
in it to attack successfully in most
positions
that's not a particularly meaningful
rule but that's just something that you
can kind of use
uh to remind yourself that you want to
bring pieces into the attack why quit
why not queen f5 instead of knight f5
because that is a check
which allows the king to drop back to
you remember that compared to the
position we were talking about
previously there is a pawn on f6
method of comparison queen can't go to
f7 you have to basically repeat moves
here
all right so
how should black of defend against this
well after knight h4 he's basically lost
but if i were playing black here i would
have played the move queen to e7
and the point is to vacate vacate the d8
square for the king
at the very least black is still in the
game although this position as you can
just see visually is miserable
all right now i mentioned i mentioned
the move knight g6 here that would have
been possible you can win material that
way
but we were going for the much greater
price of delivering checkmate
would you consider bishop take street
last last question here would you
consider bishop
takes ga so that's a good thought
because what black can no longer castle
right because the rook has moved however
that is a very valuable bishop i would
not consider this
reason enough to give up the bishop
because the bishop is a very valuable
attacker does that i hope that makes
sense
in addition black can even castle long
at some point later or he can keep his
king in the center that's not always
that bad
so i wouldn't do that i would say that
that's just not worth it
anybody have any other questions about
this game
well florence star uh foreign star
it's not nuts the logic here is that
you're doing it for a reason you're
doing it in order
to deprive black of the ability to
castle
but you're also correct that it's a very
big commit it's you know
it's really committed to do something
like this thank you chris
should we accept the center game yes you
should if you're playing black
you should accept it and made fine i
think for the prime and i am working
slowly but i'm working on a course on a
value on on refuting these these various
gambits
when can the rule f6 be broken so these
kinds of questions i can't answer
generally because that's the nature of
exceptions to rules is that they're
concrete
so there has to be some sort of greater
reason to play f6 or f3
and sometimes that reason is that it
doesn't weaken the king that much right
like sometimes you're already castled or
the king is on h1
and there is a bigger reason to play
three if you're castled on the other
side then after
the consequences of f3 are far less
significant
and their benefits are often far more
pronounced
all right um let's play one more guys
that five gifted subs put me over the
edge
i'm gonna play one more i'm really
enjoying this i think we're having a
great time
i'm having a great time and uh oh my
lands girl
let's go all right black against ortho p
from india
let's play another caro thank you zephyr
good to see you and he plays the bishop
the hillbilly bishop c4 we faced this
once before
this comes from people sometimes playing
bishop c4 against everything against the
karo khan it makes
very little sense because we play d5
with tempo
and he takes we take he's probably gonna
give a check yes
now he's moving the same piece a bunch
of times
here knight c6 is fine bishop d7 is also
fine
um it really doesn't matter both moves
are about equivalent
but we're playing very solid chess so to
emphasize the notion that you shouldn't
move a piece a bunch of times and trade
it for a piece that's only moved once
we're gonna play bishop d7 well chad is
always chill we're we're great
all right
so this is good
okay knight c3 so that's a another
slightly odd move some of you may be
attracted to the possibility of d4 but
we're not going to do that just yet
because
he'll take the bishop with check i'm a
little bit worried that that pawn on d4
is going to become weak later in the
game let's focus instead on developing
we can take his bishop and i think that
maybe some of you
are concerned about taking the issue
because his knight will appear on d
on b5 that night is right about as
innocuous as a snowflake that appears on
my elbow like you don't need to brush it
off
you can brush it off if you want so you
can play a6
but a single night on your side of the
board i think we have the subconscious
association
right where as soon as a piece appears
on your side of the board you start to
get intimidated
but remember that you start with a lot
of pieces if you keep your position
solid a single knight or a single queen
that appears on h5
is not usually going to be the end of
the world in fact you can you can use it
to your advantage because you can attack
it easily and make
improving moves with tempo his
connection
seems okay according to the vars he
takes
and to emphasize this concept right
a lot of people will play a6 a6 is a
great move but let's refrain from asics
for the time being let's just develop as
if nothing is going on because nothing
is going on
so we're just going to go knight c6 we
can also go knight f6 doesn't really
matter
yeah knight c6 knight f6 right
equivalent
yeah i'll explain e5 afterward e5 would
have been fine but not my preferred move
that's actually a very good teachable
moment
so let me write this down and i'll talk
about it after the game
okay so c3 okay
now the first thing i notice when this
move is played is that the knight no
longer has the square
as a retreating square so one move now
becomes
very timely yeah now we play a6 right
because if he goes knight d4 he ruins
his spawn structure
really badly and that's you know when
you have double pawns like that in the
center that's different right that
doesn't
what i said before doesn't mean you want
to seek out double
yes i got double pawn daniel told me
that they don't matter
double bonds do matter particularly when
they're where when they're in the center
like that
um and so that would be pretty
significant positional concession
yeah they're also isolated which makes
them even worse
right
right logo but our central control will
be equivalent so
it's actually not that bad for white
after 924 that's what he should play
well he he he might play he probably
will play knight e3
my guess is he'll play knight a3 but he
seems to be the kind of player who might
go like a4 in this position i don't know
i have a sense that
you might do something crazy um
that's like a fishing hook whatever
that's called on the other side of the
board doesn't make sense of course
but we'll see
why do all chest rules have to be so
full of nuance
because chess itself is full of nuance
i'm sorry if you came here expecting
things to be easy chess as life
should be is full of nuance now life has
for many become devoid of nuance
but that's perhaps one of the biggest
analogies
knight before the rules themselves are
very simple
all right so knight d4 to his credit he
plays knight t4 will take it
and he's okay he's really
yeah so it takes on d4 now we can play
the move e6 or we can play the move
knight f6 we can play them in any order
it really doesn't matter i'm gonna play
e6 first and i'll explain to you guys
why in just a second because we might
want to develop this knight not to f6
but say e7 but there's two things to
unpack 97 here would be bad
because it would block in the bishop we
can feed encounter the bishop but i
don't really see a reason to do that
where
should we put the bishop
right actually oh that was sarcastic
okay okay okay sorry i didn't i didn't
read the sarcasm i bet
yeah bishop d6 is a really nice square
and now we have an ultimate plan of
attacking this d4 pawn
all right that seems to be a pretty
obvious way to proceed and
we would do that with a knight first and
foremost and perhaps with a queen from
b6
but if we were to do that with a knight
then putting the knight on f6 isn't the
great
greatest idea we would put it on e7 so
that the knight could later maneuver to
one of these two squares
and put pressure on you for but first
let's castle let's not do that before we
castle
all right so
our immediate plan here is to put more
pressure on the pun
now if the question that players will
all
have and it's this is not an easy topic
even i struggle with this is what order
do you do things and do you move the
knight first or do you move the queen
first
and the only answer i have is you need
to evaluate the sort of immediate
benefits
do either of these moves have other
benefits other than what they're
intended to do
and one of the moves does kind of have
another benefit queen b6 sort of stops
the bishop from developing not
fully as i'll explain afterward but it
at least discourages the bishop from
moving
whereas had we moved the knight first he
certainly could have moved the bishop
out
he should still go but should be three
maybe not because a3
all right and now we can complete the
plan
where should we put the knight knight f5
or knight c6 both moves are fine
but i like the concept knight f5 just
seems a little bit more active just a
tad you know just a little more active
although both moves are fine
it doesn't really matter before no he
plays a really good well
actually no so okay this is gonna be a
little hard to explain
knight takes d4 is what we're probably
gonna play right now because it wins the
pawn
but i will say that in a in a real game
i probably would actually okay let's let
me try to explain this okay
so knight takes d4 is a free pawn and
black is better but he goes bishop b2
he wants to go bishop b2 right and
everybody should understand that
his bishop is going to be pretty good on
that long diagonal but if he plays
bishop b2 in the
presence of this pawn then that bishop
is going to be pretty terrible so his
bishop really has no good home
so what i'm actually going to propose
here is that we
don't take the spawn immediately but
instead focus
on opening up the queen side in order to
expose some of his other weaknesses
because i feel like this will pay off
more in the end than if we were to cash
in by taking the pawn
how can we do that well we can do that
because he's played before this is a
pretty committal move it puts that pawn
out
and we can now rip open the king the
queen side
let's move a5 right this opens up a
bunch of files this will make a weakness
on a3
and i'm happy that you guys are it seems
like you guys are understanding the
logic here
right where we might later take the pawn
but
pawns aren't the greatest prize
interested they're good
but this is a concept which you know
a lot of good players begin to fully
master which is this notion of being
flexible not always
cashing in too soon bishop d2 is a
really good move though by him
but now we're gonna take the pun and
he's gonna take back
yeah thanks all right
so he's found the best way to defend
actually because if we take on b4
he will play the move rook to b1 and he
will pin our bishop
and he will win our bishop so we have to
play
in a better way now
a consequence of our last exchange is
that the a
file has opened up and it seems pretty
natural to battle for control of that a
file if we play rook takes a1
we allow him to get control of the a
file we don't want that we want control
va file
and actually this also might be a time
to consider taking on d4 i actually
think that now is a good time to take
the pun
because we have created additional and
additional weakness on v4
he's going to have to divert some of his
attention to its defense
so by taking on d4 now we've opened up a
second
front and he might not give us another
opportunity to win the pawn so you see
how i'm like
weighing these pros and con now if he
goes bishop e3 i i think some of you are
maybe maybe worried about that what do
we do he actually might do that
what do we do in the event of bishop e3
yeah we can always take the knight with
check that's a crucial tactical detail
yeah i we had to see that when taking
the pawn there was another move that i
wanted to play initially here which i'll
explain afterward
um this is a very hard question like
when do you take the pawn when do you go
for more
these questions don't have simple
answers
yeah let me just write this down
okay so he takes so we can play um
knight takes f3 check but i honestly
don't see the reason to
to do that let's let's take there's no
reason to take on f3 and get his queen
active although we could thank you shiv
i appreciate that
also if he takes on d4 he gets our queen
active so we trade
we call it robert and i call this
trading on your own terms
trading on your own terms getting him to
be the one to take as he does and now
our queen is centralized
we need to what do we do
yeah so now we should take the bun
there's no read you know we can we can
go after this fun but
rook a2 is also good but you know what
now that most pieces have been traded
and now that we have a specific pass
pawn let's not over do over um
let's not overthink this and let's just
take the pawn
100 bits thank you maggot 83. the energy
is palpable here
oh my lands briggs digs with five gifted
girl and 200 from curious chimpanzee
and 300 from duo devin oh my god what's
going on here now
and one screw me with a prime all right
so you guys want me to lose on time
don't you
okay so how should we go about winning
this position
we're up two puns you know we have a
passer
let's play the most flexible move first
and our ultimate
goal would be to trade rooks or training
rooks will make it
much easier for us to push this passer
unobstructed
so how can we go about trading rooks
here well we have the idea of going
rocket one let's not go over k1
immediately
but we can cover that square with a
queen
and prepare okay once a queen c3 is a
good place to do it from
so it doesn't ruin the pacific the
activity of the queen
we could have also pushed the pawn we
also get uh stop him from going roxy
he's probably gonna go rogue b1
that would be a reasonable move and then
we're gonna go rook a1 and
force the queen trade or the rook trait
queen shade would be nice here too
so this is winning it's not elementary
we have to be careful
in any kind of end game like this okay
so king g2
the one thing that i would notice here
folks is the fact that our back rank
is is exposed so
we want to be very mindful of that as
we're going about our business
and particularly rookie one might not be
the best idea because he'll take
and then he'll slide his queen to c2
and that might create some unpleasant
threats i'll talk about that after the
game
now we don't need to play g6 here
because if we play g6 then he plays rook
p1 then we're gonna have a hard time
pushing our pawn
so a middle ground here is to first push
this spawn to b4
so that it's defended by the queen and
we're pushing the pawn and then
depending on what he does we'll either
bring the king out or play h6 and make
some luft
because the back ring is less exposed
our rook is now on the back rank that's
why we're not trading rooks yet
um and we're first you were going to
push the pawn to b4 it's defended by the
queen if he wants to play queen b2 and
trade queens great
uh we'll be happy with that but
then we're gonna play h6 or g6 to get
some lunch for the king and then we're
you know we can go without the rook okay
queen me too yeah so obviously we trade
now we need to defend this pawn should
we do it from a4 or should we do it from
b8
yeah so as the very famous end game
principle goes
rooks usually belong behind past bonds
and the second in-game principle is of
course that we need to involve our king
we don't want our king sitting there
so we're going to bring it in we have a
nice pathway
the third thing to remember is when you
have rook end games particularly
one of and you're up two pawns one of
the key ideas
is to use this pawn as a decoy what does
that mean
and i'll explain a little bit more
afterward we have two minutes we're
going to push this pawn onto
b3 and some of you might be saying wait
a second you're making this pawn easier
to capture now he can walk his king to
c3 and take it
and that's exactly what he's going to do
and that's exactly the point because by
taking it
he allows us to transition to a pawn end
game where not only we're up a pawn
but additionally his king is all the way
over there
so we can open up the center
and bring our own king into the king's
side that's a lot of moving parts
so what would be
the best move here well we can play e5
immediately
there is a bit of a complex reason guys
that e5 is not the best move
um and this is something i'll just have
to show you after the game we're gonna
go f6 instead to prepare it
there is sort of a very specific reason
because conceptually e5 is the best move
but he's got a defensive idea
so right now we're going to do something
pretty clever we're going to make a
waiting move
i'm going to make a way i really want
him to capture on b3
so we're going to put him in zugzwan
until he either captures on b3 or moves
his rook back and he isn't zoo zonk or
moves his king away and then we're going
to play e5 okay so he goes there
now we're going to play e5 and open up
the center we're up a pawn and upon end
game
we're winning and his king is too far
away to defend his other two bonds
there are many ways to win this the
easiest is to get to these pawns and
capture them
one by one and then we're going to have
a bunch of extra pawns
so this guy was really good i mean i
think his
his resistance was you know this pawn is
further advanced so let's drop the king
away and the red carpet is unrolled we
can just push it
and now we can track mate with the queen
the fastest would be to make a second
queen depending on where he goes
it actually doesn't matter because he's
yeah so now we'll cut him off and then
go king e3
now there's plenty of resources on
youtube and stuff for learning these
basic mates i'm not going to go over
them in too much depth
basically we make the same way we do
with the rook we pursue the king until
it reaches the corner and then we um and
then we checkmated with the queen
um now guy made it to the endgame good
game
all right the server restarts in seven
minutes so let's
dig in now the first moment at which
people had questions is this move
e5 why didn't we play e5 and this ties
into something i said
yesterday which is that thank you coco
man
which is that controlling the center is
not
a race and controlling the center
happens in two ways you control it with
pawns and you control it with pieces
and when you first start playing chess
you're often taught to play these moves
e4 d4 and e5 d5
but remember that when you control the
center only with pawns and you don't
bring your pieces out
it it disrupts the balance and those
pawns can become
themselves very vulnerable as i you know
it's become a meme now that's the nature
of
hyper modern openings right hyper modern
openings
come from people who said let's make our
opponents push all their central pawns
out so we can pick them off with our
pieces
so what do i mean by this well i can go
knight f3
and in this specific instance folks this
is fine for black because he's played so
inefficiently but i'm trying to
illustrate the concept here
the concept is that he can very quickly
start attacking our pawns
which would make it unnecessary for us
to control all of the center
so the moral here is
it's much better to control less of the
center but do it in a way that keeps the
pawn
solid then push all of our pawns to the
fourth rank and
you know watch our pawns then crumble
because we didn't develop enough pieces
all right well if we push the pawn to e4
see that's exactly the nature of the
problem we give him a beautiful square
for his knight and then you can play
d3 and undermine the spawn so
another way to look at this is space
doesn't win the game
a space advantage is something that you
have to convert into something else
so just pushing pawns for the sake of
grabbing space
is something which you have to do very
mindfully and very careful you have to
understand why you're doing it
and particularly when you push puns like
this you give up all of these squares
for your opponent's pieces
i hope that makes sense all right so
knight c6
100 bits thank you ozzie c3 is not good
he should have just developed
a6 now and we're basically because we
have five minutes until the server
restart we're gonna
fast forward here everything i did here
should be very clear
this of course was the key moment where
i didn't take on d4 let's check the
computer
i'm actually very curious yeah a5 is the
best move
a5 and it's other move is rook fch is
bringing the rook into the game
because given the way the game unfolded
it turns out that this pawn we're
actually using to our advantage we are
using this pawn as a way to make this
bishop very bad he
almost wants to take his own pawn so
that this bishop can come out to a good
square
so a5 uh bishop d2 is a great move we
take it
and here i wanted to explain what other
move i had in mind other than knight
takes d4
so um why do i want to open the queens
that's about opening the queen side and
more about creating a specific
weakness more about creating a specific
we've created a weakness
if he had taken on a5 then we would have
created another weakness
and because my pieces are more active
the way that manifests itself you might
look at this and say oh wait a second
you're
you're also having a weakness on me
strictly speaking b7 is an isolated pawn
so it's a weakness
but because our pieces are more active
we are in a much better position to
attack his weakness than he is to attack
mine
hope that makes sense um but
with the a file being opened i want to
get control of the a file
and taking on a1 is not the way to do
that because that gives him control of
the a5
how do we get control of the a-file this
is a common technique
yeah we go rook a6 so we literally
double rooks which is not intuitive here
because he's got a rook on a1
but we use the same principle if he
takes him we take with the queen and
we've won the battle
and if he doesn't do that then we double
on a8 and we will essentially force this
rook away
from anyone either to take our rook or
to move away
all right so that was also something
which attracted me but
we decided not to overthink it just to
take the pawn
given that b4 is also weak boom boom
thank you ryan
and bishop takes b4 we could have also
gone rook rook to a2
yeah so bishop c3 also probably would
have been the best move but now we can
take on f3
and here's a good tactical question for
you guys can we take on don't rush
don't rush can we take on b4 i know what
some of you are going to be thinking
but try to calculate as deeply as
possible
okay the answer is yes but those of you
saying no
say rook b1 but remember
white has a weak back rank if the rook
disappears from b1 we have control of
vfn we'll be able to play rk1
so we can take his bishop and if he says
free queen
boom goes the dynamite and he can cover
with two of his pieces but we'll take
both of them and that's back rank me
no that's fine i mean that's why i asked
the question right and this skill
calculating deeply is tied into two it's
a mindful
it's a mindset shift you have to sort of
tell yourself i'm going to calculate
past that initial knee-jerk reaction the
second thing is
the importance of tactical observations
the way that i see this quickly is
because i've already noticed beforehand
that white is a weak back ring so i'm
keeping my eyes peeled i also notice
that we have a rook on it which is
poised to go to a1
that combination of two things helps me
helps my subconscious and i'm not like
literally telling myself this
but that's how pattern recognition works
um
zesty sloth thank you for the prime all
right
so hey man thanks for another cheer so
we decided uh he took we took we take
the pawn
boom boom and yeah so queen c3
we wanted to trade rooks but he played a
very nice move king g2
quasi qazi thing with the prime we got a
hype train after rookie a1 just to
explain
takes takes queen c2 he threatens
checkman and if we create
luft he actually wins the pawn on b7
this this is uh
very hard to win so actually if you're
playing
black and you're trying to defend
against mate without giving up the pawn
you have only one move here
gh6 think about the prime yeah queen e8
then we can put the queen behind the
pawn and push this paw but what can
white do
in this position to prevent queen b8
this shows that endgames are all about
peace activity it's the side that has
the most active pieces
which often has the best time queen c7
is correct
right and now we can't play queen b and
if we push our pawn
white gets behind the pass pawn this
makes it very hard to push the spawn
and this will be hard to win so that's
the reason in short why i played it
uh b5 first then before okay he made it
easy for us by trading queens
but let's fast forward the server is
restarting i want to get this comment in
before it does
a lot of you were thinking e5 what is
the reason i delayed that mode well
after takes takes
again conceptually this is the right
idea because if he takes on b3
then our king is as close as possible to
white sponsor we can just come
in and take all of them but in this
position white is a very annoying
procedure kind of i think it's called
changing of the guard
somebody called it what piece is
blockading the b-pawn well it's the rook
he can check us on e2 normally this move
would be met with b2 like if he does
if he did that here right rookie 2
we would have pushed the pawn to b2 and
given up that pawn and
forced the transition into a pod again
which we want
but in this position he does that with
check our king has to move
and he brings his king to b2 the bottom
line is the rook is a stronger piece
than the king
the rook is harder to take down so this
is completely winning we can push our d
pawn
but this would have taken a lot longer
as you guys can understand an opponent i
think you actually grace 95.
um does that make sense
why not king f6 instead of well f6 is
fine
but i wanted to keep the king closer to
the center who knows what can happen you
know keeping the king on d6
sort of does two things at once i'm
still preparing e5 but i'm keeping the
king close to my rope just in case
king f6 is fine also king f6 blocks the
f pawn
so f6 f4 and now why am i making this
waving
well e5 it's the same problem he takes
everything goes rookie 2 and king b2
but he runs out of moves here
because if he moves his king away from
the pawn
then we play e5 and you guys might look
at this and say wait a second this is
the same thing
boom boom boom rookie two but wait a
second this king is stepped aside from
c3 so he can go king b2 king doesn't
move like a knight
he has to bring his rook back to b2 and
now we're grooving
um but if he moves his rook back
then once again we go b2 and he's again
in zooksman
so hopefully that makes sense b2 and
it's the same thing has happened in the
game
that's all there is to it this isn't
particularly hard to
i think follow and now we just come in
and win all the plots
all right um that is basically the game
so it's a long game
why didn't i play e5 before i played d4
well
his spawn if i'm not mistaken oh no his
pawn was on d4 only recently okay
i get what you're saying so i could have
played e5 before before but i wasn't
sure how i was gonna win the game yeah
this was possible
but i was a little bit worried that his
king would come in and start taking my
pawns you know i didn't want to allow
this
i wanted to bring my king in first okay
um does it matter
you could also win it with opposition at
the end yes you can win the final
position
final end game by ignoring these pawns
and
winning this as you would a position
without these fonzo king d4
because he's paralyzed he doesn't have
any pawn moves so
it's basically the same thing
you